Moi, j'suis candidate pour les élections européennes.
Je me concentre sur ces élections européennes là.
Et euh. C'est 1 chance euh,
d'être la candidate d'Emmanuel Macron,
la majorité présidentielle.
Emmanuel Macron, euh, euh,
il incarne le projet européen depuis le 1ère jour,
il a parlé d'Europe en tant que candidat à l'élection
présidentielle,
il a 1000 de l'Europe.
Débat politique français, hein,
moi, j'suis ravi que vous m'invitiez
aujourd'hui pour parler d'Europe.
Euh. Et je crois que, en deux-mille-dix-neuf, euh,
on avait déjà 1 conviction européenne très forte.
Mais aujourd'hui, plus qu'encore,
la réalité,
c'est que les événements nous ont démontré que les
français avaient
besoin d'Europe.